local high point okay or a local low
point and so we're gonna find out the
coordinates of those points okay using
our graphing calculators it works the
same for either the ti-83 or the ti-84
but let's work with the ti-84 here
that's a newer model here calculator so
what I've done is I've already inputted
an equation into y equals key right here
in the upper left hand corner y equals
and you can see I've got X cubed minus
4x squared plus 4 so I'm gonna go over
here to graph okay so there's the graph
of the equation and what I'm going to do
now is I want to find that that high
point right there okay so that that
local maximum so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna go over here to second
second calculate okay what we want is
the maximum number four so I'm going to
go to the lower right hand corner here
press Enter now you see how it says left
bound okay what we want to do is we want
an arrow just a little bit and you can
see I'm using the left and right arrow
keys I want to arrow just a little bit
to the left okay of that high point okay
so it says left bound I'm going to press
ENTER and then I'm an arrow to the right
of that high point you want to make sure
you go past the high point otherwise
it's not going to give you an accurate
value and right by one I'm going to
press ENTER okay and then it says you
can see guess I'm gonna hit enter one
more time and it finds that that high
point okay in between those two points
that we selected now you can see over
here I see this e to the negative seven
that really means scientific notation
that's eight point two times 10 to the
negative seventh which is a really small
value essentially zero so you can see
when X is zero the Y value is four okay
so if you see that you know you can see
that's very close to zero let's find the
local minimum here now we're to do the
same process we're gonna go to second
calculate and we want the minimum this
time number three so I'm gonna hit enter
in the lower right hand corner of your
calculator and I'm gonna you can see it
says left bound so I'm going to arrow
just a little bit to the left of that
that low point right there okay and I'm
gonna press Enter it says right bound
I'm an arrow just a little bit to the
right of that low point make sure I just
go a little bit past enter one more time
and it says guess you can see
press ENTER one more time and you can
see it's at two point six seven
approximately and the y-value is like
about negative five point five if you
round so that's how you find the local
maximums and local minimums using your
graphing calculator I'll see you in the
next video